wonderful and if you could give me a
warning when i've got 15 minutes left it
would be great oh sure sure thank you
okay so i guess we are ready to start
so the the next talk and the last of
this
of this whole conference will be by
robert speckins and he will be talking
about adjudicating between different
causal accounts of bell inequality
violations
please great thank you
so i
i know it's been a a long day lots of
talks before this one so first of all
thanks for you know sticking around to
the end
and of course thanks to the uh
organizers for
uh allowing people such as myself to
participate uh virtually in the
conference it's been really
interesting
so um
you know that this this conference has
really been about the interplay between
field of causal inference and the field
of quantum foundations
um and uh you know at perimeter
institute we've been
you know interested in this interplay
for a while now and i would say there's
sort of a rough categorization of
projects there's some projects where
we're
using ideas from quantum foundations uh
expertise on bell's theorem for example
to try to
improve uh state of the art techniques
and causal inference or you know answer
some interesting
questions for causal inference people uh
but then there's also the projects
wherein we sort of try to take the
ideas and conceptual framework that have
been developed in the field of causal
inference and see you know how we can
use them
to you know better understand problems
and the foundations going through
uh so you know earlier this week you
heard about some of the the work at
perimeter that was sort of about this
arrow from from ellie and from biata
and this talk is going to be about uh
the other arrow
um and so first of all i want to sort of
draw an analogy between two dichotomies
uh so you know in the field of causal
inference
i think it's fair to say that there's uh
maybe an
older perspective that's been overturned
that maybe there was a time where people
thought that you know if you give me the
data table just the statistics then that
has all the information you know about
answering questions that one's
interested in but i think you know the
the causal inference work has shown that
uh you know two different causal
hypotheses with the same data can lead
to very different conclusions so
there's more to be specified than just
the
statistical data and there's a similar
kind of dichotomy uh over on the quantum
side where there's you know
uh a certain a set of researchers who
are inclined to think that you know one
can get away with just talking about the
operational predictions of quantum
theory and what sort of data we see in
different experiments uh and then there
are other researchers that think that no
you know we need to talk about the
realist interpretation of the formalism
you know there are concepts that are not
just defined in terms of the operational
statistics um and that it's only with
that sort of realist lens that we can
really understand uh what what the
statistics is telling us so i'm of that
persuasion and so this talk is is going
to be uh to some extent about you know
achieving realism in quantum theory
um and
you know one of the things that learning
about causal inference has done for me
is it it's really changed my views about
the foundation of quantum mechanics um
and you know an idea
that i think comes out of it is is that
perhaps the the essence of achieving
realism in quantum theory is really to
to recognize that there's sort of a
minimal core of realism that you should
seek to
salvage uh which is just that
statistical correlations need to have a
causal explanation
right so often when people talk about
realist interpreters and quantum theory
that they mean a lot more than that and
and the idea i'm going to pursue here is
that like maybe this is what we really
need to do to achieve realism
and hopefully by the end i can say you
know a bit more about what what i mean
by that um but that that's the basic
idea and of course the the challenge is
that uh bell's theorem and other
examples that are like bell's theorem
involving different causal structures
like the triangle and the instrumental
structure uh they they pose a challenge
i would say to providing causal
explanations of correlations
um so
uh let's you know we've seen this over
and over the bell's theorem but let me
just sort of set up my notation and
uh
you know this is what a bell experiment
looks like and uh it's going to give you
some statistical data so it's just a
data table where i run over the the four
possible settings and the four possible
outcomes this is the kind of statistics
you you could see for particular choices
of
preparations and measurements and
predicted by quantum theory this is
possible
uh and so the the most natural causal
hypothesis you might think of is just
this one that bell wrote down that
there's some common cause that explains
the correlation between those outcomes
um
and that is natural because if you look
at the structure of the experiment it
looks very much like that's what's going
on that these two particles are really
uh what causes those outcomes to be
correlated
um but as we've seen before if i try to
model that hypothesis uh as a causal
model right so this is the dag that
represents the causal structure so in my
talk s and t are the names of the
setting variables x and y are the names
of the outcome variables
and i stipulate parameters so the
conditional probabilities for every
variable given its parents
and i compute what the possible
conditionals x y given s t are
uh then i find that that these are not
arbitrary probabilities but they satisfy
certain constraints
in particular there's the no signaling
constraints so uh what you can infer
about x
even s and t doesn't depend on t at all
uh and similarly the vice versa which we
know in in the causal influence
community get summarized by these uh
relations here x independent t given
given s so those are called no signaling
as we've seen and then the other
constraint of course is uh bell type
inequality so here i have the chsh
inequality with the outcomes and
settings of binary
and it says this this combination of the
probabilities bounded above by three
quarters
so uh you know going back to the data
this hypothesis implies the boundary
qualities this data i've chosen as uh
data that violates the billing qualities
it actually achieves the sort of maximal
violation which is called the cereals
and bound
and so these guys are incompatible and
you can conclude that it's definitely
this is not a valid causal explanation
of that data
okay so that's that's the the well-known
bit and so that this talk is more about
well how can we explain this statistical
data you know it's not this way but uh
what kinds of causal explanations could
we hope to give
and
so there are you know many ideas that
we've heard about in some of the
previous talks like sally and eric's
talk where you know there might be a
super determinist explanation or retro
causation
uh
much of what i'm going to say is is true
for sort of all attempts like that but
i'm going to focus in on this one this
is the one where there's a causal
inference from the setting on one wing
to the outcome on the other wing uh so
we saw this in tim's talk and i i would
say that uh for a certain set of people
that this is kind of the default the
most natural uh causal explanation of
the bell inequality violation so i'm
going to focus on it
um
okay so it's certainly compatible with
the data and the reason for that is that
relative to bell's model
uh now the parameter that describes how
y depends on its parents includes the
possibility of a dependence on s so that
changes what sorts of distributions i
can see
and the only constraint that this
distribution satisfy for this causal
structure that i still have that no
signaling from the right to the left so
for all choices of these parameters i'm
going to see that no signaling condition
but i can recover the sort of appearance
of no signaling
or this independence relation left to
right for particular choices of these
parameters and similarly although there
are no inequality constraints that are
implied by this i can choose these
parameters in such a way that i get
to the zeros and bound or lower than the
serotonin bound i can respect it for
certain choices of those parameters
so that that's the idea of how this sort
of causal explanation works
uh and john barrett actually uh
already sort of explained what i had
intended to explain here that you know
if you ask yourself how can no signaling
this uh independences that we see
be consistent with the existence this
causal arrow uh well it's it's
ultimately just this idea of the vernum
cipher or the one-time pad
which is that you know the cipher text
can be a some mod 2 of the plain text in
the key as long as the key is uniformly
distributed uh when i compute the the
conditional of ciphertex given plain
text i find it's it's also uniformly
distributed so it has no dependence on
on the plain text so i get this
independence of the ciphertext and the
plain text even though t is clearly a
cause
of the ciphertext because obviously if i
learn the key i can
infer the plain text from the ciphertext
um so that's essentially the idea by
which these sorts of causal explanations
that i've been talking about work so if
you look at something called the bacon
toner model of bell inequality
violations where they sort of asked
about how to simulate it with classical
communication it uses this this vertum
cipher idea where you sort of wash out
the t dependence by adding noise and if
you look at the bohmian model
which has tim pointed out involves these
sorts of causal arrows it works in
exactly the same way the same sort of
washing out phenomena
so that so it's basically it's about
choosing the the parameters here uh
carefully so that you can get that
washing out
okay so i would mention uh just that you
know these kinds of explanations already
have a kind of something uncomfortable
about them which is that um if you
thought that relativity implied not only
that signals shouldn't go fast in life
but also that causal influences
shouldn't go faster than light
then then because these
experiments can be done such the wings
are spaced like separated you know this
causal influence seems to be in tension
with that aspect of relativity
um so i'm not going to focus on that but
that's the the usual reason given for
maybe being uncomfortable with this sort
of causal explanation uh and in this
talk i'm gonna be focusing on on other
reasons to perhaps not be happy with
that causal explanation
um but before getting into that uh i
wanna talk about the
uh a second
possibility for a causal account so
again this is something we've
seen at various points in other talks uh
under the name of you know quantum
causal model so the basic idea is to say
the causal structure that bell wrote
down was right
but um we're gonna have some something
go exotic namely that there's gonna be
something like a quantum common cause
here
so so the way i i wanna formalize that
for the purpose of this talk is is to
say that the parameters that we're gonna
add on to the causal structure
aren't uh conditional probabilities
anymore so they're more exotic
mathematical objects
um
so uh matt leifer and i called these
conditional density operators so they're
operators on a
tensor product of the hilbert spaces of
the different labels here but you know
that so like row a b here will be a
joint state on uh
quantum systems a and b
and this row x given s a
is basically a measurement on a it's a
way of representing the measurement that
you do on a with outcome x and and
setting variable s
and then there's uh you can prove that
uh you know if you take the product of
these conditional density operators and
you trace over a and b so this is
the analog of summing over the lambda
variable
the latent variable in the causal model
uh you can compute the conditional
probability of x and y given s and t
um and so this uh you know this kind of
formalism is uh developed in this paper
with matt leifer as i mentioned but
there's there's a number of other uh
articles that are do more for describing
you know what what is a quantum causal
model so i think we've uh heard uh from
about
all of these uh
and there are some differences among
these proposals but but they're not
really going to be relevant for for what
i'm saying here
um
the the important thing is that if if
you look at the constraints that are
implied on this probability distribution
of outcomes given settings
you recover the no signaling constraints
for all choices of the parameters no
matter what conditional density
operators you put in here you recover
these and maybe i should mention for the
quantum folks that this conditional
density operator you know although it
showed up in john's talk i'll just
remind you that it's the general kowski
isomorphic operator to the completely
positive map that takes in s to attacks
um so right the the uh conditional
probability respects the no signaling
for all the parameters and furthermore
as i vary over these traces of
parameters i get
uh all and only the the probability
distributions that respect uh charleston
bound so you can get up to 85 here
rather than the three quarters of the
bell bound
um so this this is also compatible with
the data
uh and and so the question is now which
which of these causal explanations
should we prefer
um and so that's
most of what i want to talk about which
is you know can we give reasons for
preferring one for the other of these uh
and let me just emphasize what the
difference is here so
uh
they both are radical in one sense but
the one on the left here is radical on
the causal structure right so it says
that there's this surprising influence
uh
that you know is it can be super luminal
for example
um whereas this one is conservative on
the causal structure but if we go to the
parameters in the model this one's
conservative it's just plain vanilla
classical probability theory that we use
for making inferences about
these variables that are latent whereas
over here the claim is that it's that uh
formalism that we use to make inferences
that has become radical and exotic and
you know that the nature of the
latent system
also can't be thought of as just a set
like we could here
um okay so so that's the question uh and
i'm gonna address in two ways that the
first is gonna be
via you know thinking about empirical
adequacy and the second is gonna be more
uh theoretical
uh so yeah this part of the talk is
basically about trying to do what bell
did which is you know ask whether an
experiment can decide this sort of
question so i should say this is uh i'm
gonna be reporting on an experiment that
was done at the university of waterloo
and kevin resch's lab patrick daly was
the phd student who did the experiment
and most of the data analysis and uh i
was checking today and the article just
came out on the fizzreva website six
hours ago so i was able to give you the
actual reference
okay so the the key thing here is going
to be um you know what we mean by
empirical adequacy and i want to
contrast what we're doing with
i think uh maybe a tendency in quantum
foundations over the years to have too
low a bar on what's a satisfactory
explanation
i think a lot of times we think of you
know oh if i give a
a model or a realist interpretation all
i've really got to show is that i can
reproduce the statistical predictions of
the formalism
or you know just i have to show that
i don't under fit the data
so uh you know if in a simple example if
i just have uh two variables uh that are
related linearly this is you know the
ground truth and then i collect some
data which has statistical fluctuations
so these these blue dots are are the
data points i've collected uh then i
could you know fit a linear model to
this
uh and compute the chi squared
the sums of the squares of the
differences to give me some some notion
of how good this model is at fitting
this data
um and if i instead look at a polynomial
model uh i can again find the the best
fit polynomial the one that minimizes
this chi squared error
uh and if both of them have pretty good
chi squares i can say well they they
both do a good job they're neither one
of them underfits the data so in that
sense they're both satisfactory and
perhaps if i wanted to prefer one of
them i might say well prefer the one
that gives me the the lower chi squared
it does a better job if it would be
but of course you know this is not the
end of the story with regard to
statistical model selection there's
obviously a higher bar that you might
want to achieve which is you know what's
the predictive power of your model
so in particular you know a model can
lack predictive power not only by
under fitting the data but by
overfitting it as well so uh let me sort
of remind you what overfitting is about
so again go back to this example
if i take my data and i divide it into a
training set and a test set
then i could use the training data which
has some statistical fluctuations to to
do my fits to the model this is what my
best fit linear model looks like for
that training data and then i'll just
call the chi-squared the training error
in that case
and then for the polynomial model i can
also compute the training error um
and now the key is that i i evaluate
these models based on data that i
haven't used to to find the best fit so
that's where the test data comes in so
here's the test data it has different
statistical fluctuations
and now i define the test error to be
the chi squared uh between
the the test data and my best fit linear
model so that's the test error for my
linear model if i look at my polynomial
model i do the same thing that's my test
error for the polynomial model
um and so you know when you compare the
linear model to the polynomial model uh
you see clearly that the linear model
does a better job of predicting the data
that it hasn't seen it has a smaller
test error than does the polynomial
model
um and so it's the preferred model and
and you notice that sort of a signature
of the fact that the polynomial model is
overfitting the data is that it has
gotten a lower training error
at the expense of a higher test error
and basically what's going on here is
that it's using that extra parametric
freedom that it has
to mistake statistical fluctuations for
real features
and then it fits to those statistical
fluctuations as if they were real
features and that means it predicts the
data it hasn't seen
uh worse than the uh the model that
doesn't have that extra parametric
freedom
um okay so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna use a kind of train and test
methodology to try to adjudicate between
this this pair of
of causal accounts
um so the uh experiment we did was just
you know basic bell experiment with
binary outcome measurements uh two cupid
entangled states
but uh there's gonna be actually five
measurement settings on each week so
it's not the simple chsh setup uh it's
it's a bit more elaborate than that so
there's you know 25 measurements in
total each each has four possible
outcomes so we collect relative
frequencies of those four possible
outcomes for each of those 25 setups uh
put that into a big data table and then
uh
basically try to find you know the best
fit parameters
in this model to reproduce those
relative frequencies so try to minimize
the distance to those relative
frequencies for the probability of xy
given st that we obtain and similarly we
vary you know the parameters in this
model trying to get the best fit to that
same
frequency data
this is this is the experimental setup
it's just a basic
situation where you encode the two
qubits and polarization degrees of
freedom of single photons and
use wave plates to vary among the
measurements
um okay so these are the results uh so
over here on the left i've plotted uh
you know these bars represent the
training error and the test error of
this uh structurally radical but
parametrically conservative model and on
the right it's the training air and the
test error for this
structurally conservative but
parametrically radical model
and you'll notice that this one has more
predictive power it has a smaller test
error but furthermore you see that you
know this model has a smaller training
error which suggests that the reason it
has the worst the worst test error is
because it's overfitting and so
when we looked into it what the uh
conclusion we came to is that yes it's
overfitting the data and
and the reason is as follows that the
data because it's you know finite run
it's you know not an infinite run of
data
uh although in principle you would
expect the distribution or the outcome y
to be independent of the setting there
are statistical fluctuations away from
that so for different values of the
setting on the left you get slightly
different relative frequencies
for the the outcomes on the right
for different t values and so over here
you can mistake that statistical
fluctuation for a real feature and the
best fit model can now have y
uh depending a little bit on x having a
little bit of signaling so it can
mistake those fluctuations for actual
signaling and so the best fit model can
incorporate a bit of that signaling and
then when you ask it to predict the test
data which involves different
statistical fluctuations uh it does
worse because you know that signaling is
not really there
in the data
whereas this model over here has no
possibility none of the the parameters i
can choose will ever yield any violation
of the no signaling criteria because
it's always enforced by all the choices
and parameters
okay so the the conclusion is that this
model is disfavored by this experimental
data it has worse predictive power
um so this this ultimately supports the
conclusion of this uh
paper that i wrote with chris wood some
years ago that
was mentioned a couple of talks about
how uh
models that violate faithfulness uh uh
don't provide good explanations uh the
difference here is that we haven't
assumed the principle of faithfulness
instead this train and test method is
basically just disfavoring any
unfaithful classical causal models based
on the fact that they tend to overfit
the data
um so that
is very similar you know for the causal
influence crowd there's this paper on
bayesian causal discovery by heckerman
at all where they make the same point
that rather than using a kind of
threshold scheme where you have to set
an arbitrary
arbitrarily decide whether some data
respects
independences or not
and then you know ask whether it
faithfully reproduces the
data instead you sort of allow you know
you use the actual deviation from
independence to to get an estimate of
how likely uh a given dag was to have
generated that data so we're sort of
implementing faithfulness implicitly in
the same way that this
asian causal discovery uh scheme would
have done
um so i just want to note here that you
know uh contra to what tim maudlin said
in his talk um you know that there is an
argument here about faithfulness not not
simply an attempt to tar some idea by
choosing unflattering terminology um i i
think
it's uh
you know it's unfortunate that uh
that that was uh what tim was talking
about i think there's it would have been
more interesting if uh we had discussed
you know the the content of
the uh assumption of faithfulness and
not just the terminology
uh but i do want to get to uh
to address tim's point about booming
mechanics so for that i want to
introduce a distinction among these
kinds of classical causal models um so i
want to say that you know a classical
column model is parameter unrestricted
if i allow any conditional probability
distribution here among the parameters
um and so you know in this case
that's what allows me to violate no
signaling
but i could also imagine cases where
these are now going to be restricted so
so you know in a causal inference
context you know these might you might
consider a linear model or gaussian
distributions um but you know there's
lots of ways you'd implement this
restriction and then you may or may not
violate the no signaling condition
um
so one version of that would be what
i'll call quantum on the nose model so
bohmian the standard version of bone
mechanics would be an example of this
where this restriction has been chosen
in such a way
that the conditionals you can get here x
y given st are all and only the ones
that are predicted uh by quantum theory
um and so if you do that then you can't
violate the no signaling condition
because you know the the formalism of
quantum theory doesn't allow you to
violate that condition so you're going
to respect it as well
um
there's a different way of restricting
the parameters uh which i'll call you
know quantum extending models so they
include the quantum predictions but more
besides
and so anthony valentini has a version
of bohmian mechanics
uh which actually makes different
predictions to standard quantum theory
uh
they do involve a restriction if i try
to cast his version bone mechanics in
the mold of a causal model it will be a
restriction of the kinds of parameters
uh but not one that gets you precisely
to the the quantum predictions um so it
has more leeway and therefore it can
violate signaling and valentini predicts
that we should if if his version of bone
mechanics is true we should be able to
see uh signaling in certain
circumstances
um okay so the the experiment uh
i described dis favors this first class
right so anybody who says oh it's easy
to explain bell inequality violations i
just need to incorporate these interlab
causal influences and i don't need to
bother to stipulate any model i think
this is a good argument against that
position that that
you know those sorts of explanations
tend to overfit the data relative to
this idea of a quantum causal model
um
these quantum extending models like
valentini's version of bone mechanics
you know we didn't explicitly consider
them uh in our analysis so we we did not
encode the specific restriction they
imply
uh we didn't figure out exactly what the
specific restriction that was implied so
strictly speaking you know we don't rule
this out but in principle the kind of
technique we described could if you went
and encoded that restriction and you
tried to do the experiment in the
context where valentina thinks that you
really might see signaling it would be a
way of testing that idea and finding out
whether uh it really
uh overfits the data relative to the
quant causal model or not
um but if you look at one of these
quantum on the nose models then they
strictly speaking have exactly the same
predictive power as as one of these
parametrically radical models um because
they satisfy the no signal so they're
not going to be prone to any overfitting
uh because they cannot choose any
parameters that would yield signaling so
there this kind of uh technique that i
described is is not going to be able to
rule out the standard version of bone
mechanics if you think that the right
way of formalizing that notion in the
causal model framework is is in terms of
restriction
so i think you know and interesting yes
just telling you 15 minutes oh thank you
uh so
so it's an interesting question um you
know
what kind of reasons can be given if you
try to think of bone mechanics from the
perspective of this sort of framework
for formalizing physical theories is
there a good reason that can be given in
favor of this kind of restriction on the
parameters um you know i think in in
valentini's version there's kind of a
story about dynamical equilibrium that
achieves a kind of
near
matching to the quantum predictions um
but i i don't really want to talk about
that today uh instead i want to take a
different kind of tact uh which is to
consider not just the standard version
of bone mechanics but really any
one of these parameter restricted
quantum on the nose uh call the models
uh and i want to try to give an argument
for why we should still
uh think that there's a kind of
uncomfortable tension between the
existence of this causal influence and
the fact that we see no signaling from
the left to the right
so that's this this second topic which
is
trying to adjudicate between these these
two models these two types of models uh
based not on you know empirical data but
on a theoretical principle
so this is uh work that's still uh not
on the archive yet with david schmidt
and john selby um and it seems to me
that there's some uh
close connections to some papers that
are already out there one by eric
carlitanti and one by catania woofer
um okay so the the theoretical principle
uh that i'm going to appeal to
is uh what i like to call the leibnizian
methodological principle um so it's a
methodological principle for how to
construct you know realist theories
and and the basic idea
i mean it goes back to the principle of
sufficient reason but i like to think of
it as the
ontological identity of empirical
indiscernibles um
so so here's here's my version of it
which is
if if a realist physical theory posits
two scenarios that are empirically
indistinguishable in principle
but nonetheless that those two scenarios
are represented as ontologically
distinct
uh then you should throw this theory out
and replace it with one where these two
scenarios are ontologically the same
that that's the idea
and
you know the this in principle here is
playing an important role that empirical
indistinguishability is not some
parochial notion but like oh i just
didn't do the experiment well enough and
and you know maybe my failings as a
human didn't allow me to empirically
distinguish them but it really means
uh in principle by the lights of that
physical theory so the physical theory
has to say you know it could never be
distinguished even in principle even
with technology one billion years from
now you know and anything living in the
universe subject to its physical laws
could not distinguish it
so so leibniz used this kind of
principle to uh argue against newton's
notion of absolute space you know the
argument being that if you know you move
all the particles in absolute space over
by five feet nothing you observe changes
at all and therefore you know any
theoretical framework that assumes the
existence of apps in space runs afoul of
this sort of principle we can't give any
reason for why the universe should have
been here as opposed to there so it's a
bad model of reality
um
i i think it's a reasonable principle
but if you ask you know why should you
believe it when you're building physical
theories i think the best answer
is that it has really impressive
credentials um
einstein i argue used it it was a really
important principle in his development
of both the special and general theories
of relativity so i don't have time to go
into why that's the case but uh you can
read about it in this paper um but
basically his argument against the
electromagnetic ether in the beginning
of his 1905 paper is basically an appeal
the leibniz's principle his uh you know
the foundation of general relativity
which is the equivalence principle is
also an appeal to leibniz and then that
the final obstacle he had to overcome in
developing general activity was
understanding something called the whole
argument and uh i argue in my paper that
that's also
uh an endorsement of the blindness
principle so for all those reasons i
think it's it's an important principle
for physicists you know to take note of
and to try to incorporate into their
theorizing
uh and i'm going to use a slightly
variant of it relative to what i just
explained which is sort of a
generalization to the case
of physical theories where there might
be some uncertainty so theories like
statistical mechanics or quantum
mechanics where you don't have a
description of all uh
you know the fundamental degrees of
freedom and in that context the way uh
it gets used is to say that if you have
two states of knowledge concerning
operational facts empirical facts
uh and they're perhaps different but
equivalent for the purposes of making
inferences they allow you to make
exactly the same inferences about other
operational facts
then when you try to represent that in
your underlying realist theory so now
you're talking about state of knowledge
of some underlying facts about reality
uh that those two states of knowledge
should also allow you you know should
have you make the same inferences about
other
uh realist facts
um so this is my attempt to sort of give
it a
uh you know make sense of it but really
there's a formal definition which you
can find in in this paper
and it would you know take too much time
to introduce all the formalism to to
really uh say this properly but
hopefully i can
make the application of the principle
plausible uh in the context that i i
want to apply it
so here here's that context it's so
we're back to the bell experiment
um so now i want to imagine a slight
variation where over here on the right
uh we don't imagine that we just have
say two settings like in chsh
experiment but we really imagine that we
could do any measurement at all on the
systems coming into bob's lab um so
that's that's the change
um and
and you know if we believe quantum
theory then even though i do any old
measurement i like i'm still not going
to see signaling that the the choice of
the setting over here in alice's lab is
not going to change the the distribution
over the outcomes of it for any
measurement at all
all right so if i look at uh the the
causal structure sorry uh the causal
structure that's posited uh in these
models that involve the interlab causal
influence so now i've just dropped this
t setting variable and just written the
outcome here y sub n
um i can always you know without loss of
generality imagine some causal mediary
i'll call it lambda prime that sort of
mediates the influence from the parents
of y on y
um
okay so so that's just sort of for
convenience
and now the point is that um
you know this this measurement i do over
on the right hand system
uh you know is really in my realist view
you know a measurement on the properties
of this lambda prime causal meteor
variable
and it has this feature that you know
it's the outcome of these measurements
are independent of the setting s for all
measurements i might do it and that as i
said is true
if you're positing one of these
parameter restricted quantum on the nose
models you're saying that quantum theory
gets things right
and quantum theory predicts that you'll
see no signaling no matter what
measurement you do
so what the leibnizian methodological
principle tells you is that if that's
the case then lambda prime itself should
be
independent of s
um and the reason for that is that if if
it weren't if different values of s led
to different probability distributions
over lambda prime that would mean that
you know learning s would allow me to
infer different things about lambda
prime you know for different values of s
even though i infer exactly the same
things about the outcomes of any
measurement so it would be an example of
a difference in the at the ontological
level that had no uh empirical
counterpart there was no observation
that would allow me to see the
difference between those different
distributions
over lambda prime for different values
of s
okay so that's that's where the the
principle gets applied so now i can
finish the argument
so if you want to satisfy this principle
then this fragment this this part of our
causal structure so here i've just
dropped
this piece here and i've made this
circle black because for a moment i'm
going to sort of be thinking about this
as as if it were observed
um so this this fragment of the causal
structure you know should have a set of
parameters describing how every variable
depends on its parents
uh that are restricted in such a way
that lambda prime comes out independent
of x you know we know that doesn't
that's fine given that the causal arrow
here because we can use a burnham cipher
trick
to ensure that independence but that's
what we need if we want to satisfy
leibniz
uh and now here's the critical bit it
turns out that any distribution over x
lambda prime and s that i can get here
with this restriction i could also get
in this causal structure where the arrow
from s to lambda prime is dropped
and that's because every distribution x
lambda prime given s
uh that uh has this independence is
achievable in this day so we already saw
that at the beginning of uh rob and
evan's talk because this dag here which
has a common cause connection between
these guys
is observation equivalent to the case
where i have an arrow from lambda prime
to f so it's just the collider on x
and you know it's well known that the
collider on x can give you every
distribution where the the causes are
independent
so so any trace of parameters here that
gives me some distribution i can
simulate it here
all right so that means
that you know back back in my original
causal structure
i i can replace this little fragment
here you know if it's a leibnizian model
then this little fragment here can be
replaced by the one that doesn't have
the arrow but of course this i can just
drop this causal mediary this is just
the plain old bell structure again and
so any distribution that is achievable
with this model in a leibnizian way also
satisfies the balance columns
um so okay what's the summary
if you consider these parameter
restricted quantum on the nose models
with the cos effect influence here and
you demand to respect this principle you
can't recover bell equality violations
and therefore if you have sorry if you
have a model like this that does recover
bill inequality violations then it must
violate this uh leibnizian principle and
that's in fact what happens in in bowman
mechanics that the
distribution like this lambda prime and
bone mechanics is like the particle
configuration
over on bob's side and the distribution
over that variable does indeed depend on
uh
the the setting over analysis lab even
though no measurement you do on it you
can see that difference
um so that so that's the the argument as
to you know why you might
not be so keen on this causal account uh
if you're excited about the leibniz
methodological principle i think it's an
important principle and you shouldn't
violate it uh if you think this is a
problem then you ought not to be happy
with this kind of model
okay so i think i have just a couple of
minutes i'll wrap up um
i want to clarify that
it's not the case that this other option
these sort of parametrically radical
causal models that are
structurally conservative what people
have called quantum calls and models
throughout the conference it's not as if
they're completely unproblematic and
everything's done this is this is more i
would say still a research program so uh
i don't think we yet have a satisfactory
causal explanation of bell inequality
violations um and the reason is that i
think
you know these parameters have to be
interpreted in a very specific way if
i'm going to think of the formalism of
quantum mechanics as
being a kind you know think of it from
the causal modeling perspective
these ought to play the role of uh
you know part of a theory of inference
classically they're conditional
probabilities they're part of a
framework of asian probability theory
and and so in the quantum case we need
to
we can't just declare by fiat that all
this stuff can be thought of as you know
how you should update your beliefs about
one variable given other variables you
have to really show that that's the case
and that's what hasn't uh been done
uh you know there's been a sort of
progression of ideas for how to do this
this third paper shows a kind of uh
significant restriction on the
possibility of doing that
some of what john barrett talked about
and
you'll find in in these papers
um kind of improves on the situation
gets a bit further
but my perspective these days is that
all those attempts
could not have succeeded because there
was a an unscrambling of causal and
inferential notions that still remains
to be done but there was still sort of a
confusion between causation and
inference that was persisting
uh and so i don't have time to talk
about it but um there's a recent paper
with david schmidt and john selby that
that tries to kind of
set uh
the research program in a new direction
by sort of
articulating what further unscrambling
needs to be done
um so let me let me just finish by
saying you know that going back to the
beginning
this is a bit of a description of what
we're trying to achieve in this paper um
we're trying to achieve a realist
account of quantum correlations and what
we mean by that is that
we want a theory of causation a theory
of inference uh that can explain the
observed statistical correlations while
salvaging this leibnizian methodological
principle
and therefore you know the spirit of
locality and non-contextuality
uh which are basically instances of that
uh principle
and essentially you know the way we do
it is we say well the classical theory
of what causation is just like sets and
functions and the classical theory of
what inference is which is you know
bayesian probability theory boolean
logic
those need to be modified uh we need to
have
some sort of what i'll call
intrinsically quantum variants of those
and therefore an intrinsically quantum
notion of realism
and it's that sort of framework uh where
i think we can achieve a satisfactory
causal explanation
so
that's it thanks very much for your
attention
questions
so you know there's there would be way
too much to talk about but let me just
hit two points um
your leibnizian principle
sure newton violates it as soon as he
postulates a euclidean space because the
euclidean space has translational and
rotational symmetries which allow for
ontologically distinct situations that
are observationally indistinguishable
um he does it to explain the bucket and
and leibniz couldn't explain the bucket
right i mean leibniz loses that
particular
barber
i think barbara and bertotti did it
yeah i don't think barbara live next win
but again i don't want to get too far
into that if you say einstein was using
it einstein at the end of 1905 has flat
minkowski space-time which has
translational and rotational symmetry
just like newtonian absolute space
so you would say he violates the he he
gets to a theory that violates it too
so that's just historical but i think i
i just i disagree with both those points
i just want to say that okay if you
think minkowski space flatman kowalski
space time is not what special
relativity gives you okay you have a no
i disagree with the idea that einstein
didn't endorse leibniz's principle i
think if you look at einstein's writing
he endorses it all over the place but
what i just said was the theory he comes
to violates it but he didn't land with
that gear he landed with general
relativity right just like we landed
with barbara bertotti in the end as the
correct relational account yeah okay so
anyway that would be but the main thing
is look um
of course it's surprising if there are
non-local causal connections
that you don't see non-local signal
right
that's surprising and you might say why
is
that and the normal answer is in a
bohmian perspective because you're in
quantum equilibrium
and just as in thermo there are lots of
really interesting thermodynamic
principles
that just you know you can
explain all kinds of things and say
don't try to build this because it would
violate the second law
but we know the the standard account is
the second law can be violated right you
don't want to build that into the
fundamental physics what you do is
explain
why typically it won't be
by statistical considerations and that's
just what happens
so i would say to that that i think the
the version
of an equilibrium argument that makes
sense to me
is the one that valentini proposed
wherein there's this notion of you know
that the particle configuration bone
mechanics need not have been exactly psi
squared there could be deviations if
that is one's point of view then as i
noted it's possible in principle to
adjudicate between that point of view
using empirical data my guess is that
you know the experiments will continue
to find that any such point of view that
allows in principle for signaling
because it allows in principle for sub
quantum non-equilibrium will actually be
found to be you know over fitting the
data i i don't think the experiments are
going to support that point of view so
all right so again i'll just say this
i'm sorry if people can't follow this
from a bohmian perspective
there's no initial
distribution there's a single point
there's one point one initial
configuration
and what the arguments show in these
arguments that shelley and detlef and
nino gave
is that a typical initial point
will give you born statistics on
subsystems
a typical initial point it doesn't have
to be psi squared how do i define
typicality use side to the fourth use
side of the eighth
by any of those definitions a typical
initial point will give you born
statistics
and so yeah yeah i guess i i
personally i don't find those typicality
arguments to be persuasive if you you
know that there is something that you
know has to go like psi squared which is
the probability distribution that
describes you know what we know about
the bohmian configuration and if you
allow that to deviate from psi squared
then you're opening up the possibility
for signaling so i i think we disagree
about the status of those arguments i
mean i i'm on valentini's side regarding
that
[Music]
thanks rob that was really nice talk um
i share your sentiment that i don't
think quantum causal models are all the
way there to um provide good
descriptions of the bell inequalities
and i'm just interested in um whether
you think uh the kind of the direction
that you're heading
par if part of that project is to kind
of explain the serial sunbound for
example
rather than pr boxes whether that's part
of it or whether that is a question
that's kind of orthogonal to what you're
doing thanks
okay thanks for the question yeah that
that's definitely a part of it that uh
you know i i think the
accidentization trend in quantum
foundations is is absolutely uh
the right way to go that i would
characterize you know
there was a time where quantum
foundations was you know very concerned
with taking the quantum formalism as
given and adding a story about reality
to it
whereas more recently we've been trying
to say can we derive the details of the
quantum formalism from some principles
and so sort of my take on that is that
you know those principles are ultimately
going to be about
uh you know the nature of causation and
the nature of inference and how they're
kind of slightly different in in a
quantum world compared to a classical
world and those are the principles by
which we'll be able to derive the
quantum formalism and therefore in
particular explain that we get just to
the surrealism bound and and no further
than that cyril's inbound um so i i
think you know the reason that that i
think that's the the sort of right
approach to take is that a lot of the
old interpretational stories like you
know bowman mechanics or everett or
collapse theories you know from a modern
perspective i can take those stories and
i can look at a formula that different
from quantum theory like any
a generalized probabilistic theory like
box world or my toy theory or any of
another and you can add that story to
them so there's nothing about those
stories that you know pick out the
quantum formalism from among a number of
other ways the world could have been and
so that that to my mind uh makes it
clear that you know that those stories
clearly have less uh
you know power to explain why the world
is quantum
than an axiomatic derivation of the
formalism starting from principles
um thanks so there is a person who
raised their hand online so the person
can maybe ask the question
thank you can you hear me
yes yes oh okay thanks for the talk um
well i have a
question regarding uh what else
what is involved in this as you put it
the scrambling of the omelette of
causation
i i've seen your paper it's pretty long
i'm just curious to know what exactly do
you think that
um needs to be done right now what
further unscrambling
right um
so
you know
in the past
we we focused on completely positive
maps it's kind of the the quantum analog
of conditional probabilities
and we thought hey conditional
probabilities those are you know like
think of it as a stochastic matrix p b
given a we thought oh those are clearly
just things that live in an inferential
theory they're about your you know the
inferences you can make about b given a
and uh you know there's there's nothing
problematic there but what we realized
in this work was that um
if you have the following situation
where i just have you know a is a bit
and b is a bit
we want to say that you know that the
causal connection that could
connect hb
is just a function and there's only four
uh different bit-to-bit functions
there's the the constant function
identity there's the flip
and then there's you know reset the bit
to zero regardless of what value it had
or reset the bit to one
that's it
and now you could have knowledge about
what that function is so you might for
example just assign equal probability to
it being identity or flip that's one
state of knowledge you might have a
second state of knowledge you might have
is equal probability that it's reset to
zero or reset to one
and it turns out that both of those
states of knowledge you know that they
they have completely different support
on on the you know the function so
they're consistent with completely
different uh causal relations in the
world
uh in one case identity and flip a and b
are causally connected in the other case
they're causally disconnected
they give the same stochastic matrix
they both uh say that the stochastic
matrix b given a
is just you know the the randomizing
channel and so that's the sense in which
these stochastic matrices they they
scramble together causal and inferential
concepts if you just give me the
stochastic matrix i don't know whether
it's ignorance about two ways that a and
b might be causally connected
or ignorance about two ways in which
they may be causally disconnected so
that's why we think you know we ought
not to focus on those stochastic
matrices
and the quantum analog of that the cp
map that also
we think you know therefore scrambles
you know causal and inferential notions
and what we need on the quantum side is
more like the analog of a probability
distribution or function that's the
thing that we need to figure out on the
quantum side
so i hope i hope that
yeah it does thank you
thank you very much then if there are no
more questions let's thank the speaker
again and all the speakers of this
session
yeah so just to wrap up here uh i was
saying to other people i'd like